Eldon rings perfumers for once blessed
apothecaries who brought relief even to
the impure and the Miss begotten so how
did they go from that to this firing
poisonous ballista Bolts from the walls
of Lane Dell well in the beginning the
perfumers were quite loyal to the Earth
tree and even embroidered its design
onto their heavy aprons to symbolize the
weight of their Duty and pride but when
the shattering War Began they were
drafted into it forced to replace the
aromatics with poisons and explosives
the uplifting aromatic in particular
made them exceptional commanders for it
turned their troops Fearless in the face
of death but nevertheless the war
dragged on and eventually even the Earth
trees rule that prohibited the use of
fire was forgotten and these days most
perfumers imbibe of their mind-altering
spices for themselves alone their
descent into depravity is absolute and
now a new accursed symbol can be found
embroidered upon their aprons a curse
upon the Earth tree whose War corrupted
their once blessed order